et il y à un mot qui
parle c'est là prédit
quelque chose qui vient de très très
loin très loin en arrière bien avant la
naissance
socrates d'ailleurs dit il dit on est
pour réapprendre
alors je vous dis ça parce que
finalement mon parcours est allé assez
banale au début une scolarité très
médiocre je les ai testés l'école je
supportais pas d'être en groupe je
supportais pas d'être enfermé dans un
local dans une pièce assise toute une
journée
voilà j'en voyais pas l'intérêt
mes parents bienveillants m'ont permis
de commencer la musique par le piano un
instrument que beaucoup font au début
j'ai commencé très jeune donc et mon
professeur de piano c'était des cours
privés au début mon professeur de piano
enseigner de façon traditionnelle série
avait des gammes marc vente
il y avait la méthode rose barbante
aussi il y avait le solfège très très
barbe en bref donc ils avaient pourtant
envie de jouer comme les autres voilà
j'avais très envie que c'est touche ces
différentes notes me parle
j'arrive à faire sortir des sons que
j'avais déjà dans la tête
donc j'ai improvisé j'ai improvisé
je me suis raconter des histoires en
musique d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu ce
qui m'a permis d'aller si loin en
musique c'est que pour moi c'est bien
plus que des sceaux c'est bien plus que
des notes
il ya des parfums il ya des couleurs il
ya des odeurs il ya tout lié vraiment ce
qu'est la musique traverse peu comme le
vent vous savez comme le cône l'amour
comme la spiritualité géant lire et donc
je vais improviser et à travers
l'improvisation vous de suivi créé mon
propre technique ça manger trouver mon
propre chemin d'accès alors bien sûr
tout seul sans bagages ça donne pas
grand chose donc après cela j'ai écouté
énormément de musique qui était gourmand
de tous les répertoires je me souviens
je vais commencer par là les hyènes de
bizet avec des thèmes provençaux musique
festive
j'étais plus loin vt bouleversé par le
requiem de mozart
et puis alors après quelques années de
piano
je suis rentrée au conservatoire pareil
faisait pas grand chose j'ai été viré du
conservatoire d'angoulême
bien sûr quand je travaillais pas
c'était normal je travaillais pas je
travaillais tout à fait autre chose que
ce que l'on donné et puis donc une fois
viré il fallait bien que je continue à
faire de la musique et que je développe
quelque chose en moi
donc ma mère a eu l'idée de m'emmener à
la cathédrale d'angoulême ne savais pas
qu'un jour je deviendrais un titulaire
et là j'ai été ébloui par l'instrument
c'est vrai que l'homélie ça me disait
pas grand chose par contre la musique
oui elle me parlait là j'entendais un
vrai prêche c'est à dire qu' il y avait
une voix qui qui me transfiguré c'est
que j'avais quelque chose là je vous dis
encore qui traversait et qui m'a mené
vers des auteurs que je pouvais pas
soupçonner moi j'appelle ça maintenant
dieu voilà
et donc j'ai entendu du bac et là je
suis tombé fou amoureux de bacs de cette
musique pour moi le plus grand le plus
grand des prêcheurs et à travers cette
musique j'ai trouvé ma vocation
je savais que ce serait ça et ce serait
la composition donc je suis rentré à
nouveau conservatoire en orgue et on m'a
réintégré en piano et la l'improvisation
m'a donné la forte envie de créer deux
composés ne pas rester sur un harki
fugitif et qui est fait via banc pour
disparaître et surtout qui reste quand
même non seulement éphémère les cas pas
même ses limites
alors que la composition comme c'est
écrit on peut effacer on peut aller en
arrière revenir peaufiner la structure
voilà donc j ai bien ce moment là j'ai
eu très envie de m'investir au
conservatoire il faut s'il devient
amoureux du solfège
parce que j'avais rejeter au début parce
que ça me servais la voilà donc tout ce
qui était tonalité tout ce qui était
théorie moindre signe l'orchestration
l'harmonie le contrepoint l'affût de
tout ça j'en avais absolument besoin
donc je suis allé je suis allé à la
recherche plus loin que le conservatoire
c'est étudié tous les hits
d'orchestration que je pouvais trouver
il est décrit frais normes et man lui
tout ce que je trouvais comme musique et
j'ai créé mon propre langage à travers
des fois parce que finalement quand on
est créateur on est créateur par rapport
à ses envies c'est à dire qu'on fait des
choix on note puisque ce qui nous plaît
on les gants le gard depuis ce qui nous
plaît pas on fait et ça crée un style ça
crée un style donc j'ai voulu créer
après plusieurs tâtonnements puisque
c'est le travail du créateur ces deux
des trente ans tâtonnements perpétuel et
temps en temps de trouver une pierre
précieuse
j'ai trouvé une technique pour la
composition c'est l'entraînement c'est
vraiment écrire même quand on n'a rien à
dire j'ai envie de dire écrire écrire je
t'ai énormément et garder un peu de
temps en temps cet entraînement a mouse
vers des portes ou vers un ciel
voilà a donné une incarnation et puis
alors j'ai écrit à quoi tu raccorde de
quatuor à cordes des pièces pour piano
des pièces pour harmonieux pour quatuor
de cuivres public et ma première grande
oeuvre une messe une messe pour un
siècle nouveau c'est en l'an 2000 donc
c'est pas je vais pas chercher loin pour
le titre qui a eu du succès plus tard
c'est à dire une dizaine d'années écrit
un requiem et là j'ai eu une révélation
d'abord l'oeuvre a été créé à la
madeleine l'église de la madeleine à
paris vous savez ces femmes l'église où
a été créé l'oeuvre 200 titulaire de
l'époque c'est-à-dire fort et gabriel
fauré donc il y avait une symbolique
très forte et en plus l'organisme la
madeleine qui est françois henri houbart
participé à la création
il y avait un double coeur de zorg un
piano et quatre solistes ce qui est
unique dans le dans l'orchestration
musicale
cette formation plus droit à un
documentaire consacré exclusivement à
l'oeuvre
incroyable et puis bon je voulais aller
encore plus loin dans la musique mais
comme je vous disais bien au delà de la
musique c'est à dire une recherche un
temps pour elle un besoin de rencontrer
dieu l'absolu et et surtout me de me
trouver non seulement de marcher dans
les pas de jésus mais aussi d'être
ébloui par la lumière par cette cette
lumière joue parle de musique il faut
pas le de lumière voiliers et l'un va
avec l'autre
donc j'ai écrit une passion vous allez
en entendre un extrait en temps de la
fin de la passion juste après mon
intervention
et je peux vous dire en fait les écrits
après avoir couru j'attendais cette
partie là j'attendais des réunions assez
angoissante et finalement j'étais dans
le cas où ça et ça va expliquer une
chose devait pour pour engendrer une
étoile qui danse il faut être dans le
cas où
et finalement je vis cette tare 7e cette
création à la fois dans une paix dans
une paix mais aussi dans un certain cas
où le cas vous qui est propre à la
création et qui engendre la lumière et
la beauté et les étoiles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et comme jésus
et
non
[Musique]
oh
dans le rang
[Musique]
j
[Applaudissements]